[ __ ] you bad [ __ ] Sunday night
special edition
[Music]
[Laughter]
you wanted it you got it [ __ ]
special edition Sunday night the Church
of what's happening ski teach ski cheek
what is happening here nothing's
happening is terrible 18 of them
[Music]
[Music]
call the cops call whatever the [ __ ] you
need to call it's a week before [ __ ]
Easter leaves and training is [ __ ] and
he can't spit them back into the cup
[Music]
oh [ __ ] there's a fire up in this
[ __ ] call 9-1-1 either that
Hitler's burdensome me I'm saying it was
barbecuing you had a fun time yesterday
you watch Chris Knight me Chris Weidman
get hit in the head
you watched Anthony Rumble retire now
it's all over it's time funcle' Joey
Lisa hat and the church army understand
oh my god Hitler's barbecue time clock
that mama I'm going up to them we got
any the head three me time don't go to a
podcast but I love little church with a
bargain sure this is a good stuff
[Music]
BAM oh [ __ ] [ __ ] up this Sunday night
Aerosmith rocks who's better than you
you said [ __ ] dinner I'm even a TV
dinner and I'm hanging out with Uncle
Joe we would open up the podcast with my
manly look at the Stars oh [ __ ] repping
Boston we [ __ ] around tonight Doug
that's the [ __ ] bond of death that's
the mule I told them to train this
weekend we didn't want to believe me we
got the meal this weekend it's all oh
but the shop drool face is turning red
the whole [ __ ] deal I put water in
there there's water there's carbonated
water that club soda I got everything in
this [ __ ] greetings got [ __ ]
your uncle Joey on a Sunday night April
night there you go
get the spirits out of the room you know
I'm saying and if you're an 18
[ __ ] don't even think about it
hang up right [ __ ] now
I don't need this [ __ ] I'm right here
[Music]
you'll [ __ ] you think you're dealing
what you think I forgot about you
[ __ ] huh
where you going with those stars leave
him right there no he dumped some on the
trash and [ __ ] but if you're smoking
reefer
you gotta hydrate you know I'm saying
it's the only way to [ __ ] do it
it's a beautiful day to be alive you got
the world by the balls leave setup I
will you beside it behind my girlfriend
left me for a [ __ ] Bongo player who
gives a [ __ ] get her out of there with
that nasty [ __ ] monkey it's time for
you to make a comeback I'll come back
like [ __ ] Aerosmith and 75 feet off
the H getting it from the Chinese [ __ ]
number two and look at them they put
together one of the best albums in the
history of [ __ ] rock and roll
if you don't know now you know here we
go
[Music]
the [ __ ] you think you're [ __ ] we're
here his uncle Joey Sunday night some
people go to church and hang out with
the pervert breeze whatever you hear
what your uncle
this is the best church you'll ever get
this is the best bang for your [ __ ]
Dappy understand me every once in a
while you might have to [ __ ] buy some
underwear or something but besides that
you'd covered
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there he is my brother
from a different mother you never came
in mister be the [ __ ] strip club no
we're here we were hangout white people
over there were like mr. Jefferson West
yeah
like mr. Jefferson so that said it's
Sunday night you're sitting there
thinking to yourself what am I gonna do
with my life you could watch the church
or what's happening now [ __ ] Bob
what's going on with those stars they
give him up for [ __ ] when I breathe
who breathes I was tickled by you last
night I was watching two nights ago I
was watching dirty 4:30 Detroit Pistons
god damn that's [ __ ] the Jordan rule
were they the rule was just hammer him
every time he comes down [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] tremendous and it was like they
had a team and all sudden two guys
showed up I think it was Mahorn and or
nothin at all Sally the best eight man
of all time and [ __ ] uh to rebound the
Madonna's boyfriend right let's show the
man if you haven't seen great I think
dirty fraternity is the best show on
television there's not a boring one even
if you don't like the [ __ ] sport you
like let me watch it because all the
other ones that make it really
interesting yeah
[Music]
yes yes yes yes
that was good we had the guy Chris and
basketball playing here yeah you see
that one that one was deep yeah yeah
Sacramento the King brothers had that
that's that's my world I think that's
your world too
Bernard King was playing in New York I
would go over there just I didn't give a
[ __ ] just to watch him nobody was and
then one week he went off one week he
took it deep in the murky waters easy
he hit 60 twice in one week like a
Thursday and then like the following two
something like that ten days apart man I
fell in love with Bernard King when I
was probably in the seventh grade and
then he moved to what's Edgewater New
Jersey now he moved to like Fort Lee for
him to play basketball he would play at
night after midnight when they got dark
top his everybody will bother and we
caught a winter that
and we went up there one day and we
started watching them behind the rocks
and then he would be our lone court and
we would just make believe like we were
like an eighth grade what are you doing
we just gonna play ball on this side you
know like that's how [ __ ] up we were
we would lie to our parents so all I
finalists could [ __ ] take the number
one bus then we sit in the weeds like
Vietnam vets and then Bernard King he
could either show up or he wouldn't run
this isn't he was clean there was no
lights there was the lights from the
road yeah street lights there's no
lights in the [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah the [ __ ] you're doing with your
life get it together guys do a bong hit
loosen up the lolly you ready for
another banana one you got to mourn able
to go find another please on a [ __ ]
scourge later he's eat another mm
tonight 2200 he's going deep in the
murky waters stars of death
if you didn't have money for a denzel's
heroin that's what they gave me instead
for 15 cents you in town this week I was
yet
thousand say-so Thursday my vision
oh we don't know me
you would think maybe guests on the show
[Music]
they were worried about
[Music]
[Music]
yeah they come in from out of town just
to fight
[Music]
they got some new [ __ ] they're doing
some crazy [ __ ] we've this one is
[ __ ] [ __ ] here this was grown like a
flight dungeon by six midgets [ __ ]
with whips [ __ ] look at this we're gonna
[ __ ] who you want to run it this is
death right here this is this is the
[ __ ] I put in the safe for when the
zombie apocalypse or [ __ ] the Korean
somebody drop something this [ __ ] will
kill you look at this these are
beautiful tight little [ __ ] buds of
death I've been cultivating them saving
them look at this this is for a good
[ __ ] week you follow me I'm gonna let
it dry the [ __ ] fault and you put it
in the safe this is high-end youtube.com
slash church slash slash see sighs Joey
Diaz see you [ __ ] in ten minutes
stay black